what is a man with new test a man with
the utest tests whether there is a
difference between two independent
samples an example is there a difference
between the reaction time of women and
men but the t-test for independent
samples does the same the man with the
u-test is the non-parametric counterpart
to the t-test for independent samples
the t-test for independent samples tests
whether there is a mean difference for
both samples the mean value is
calculated and it is tested whether
these mean values differ significantly
the man with new test checks whether
there is a rank sum difference for this
purpose we sort all persons from the
smallest to the largest value this
person has the smallest value so gets
rank 1. this person has the second
smallest value and so on and so forth
then we can simply add up the ranks of
the first group and the second group now
we can investigate whether there is a
significant difference between these
rank sums